so we're going to start with a growing
crisis at the southern border of the
United States a large number of Asylum
Seekers are continuing to cross over
from Mexico let's go straight to Al
jazeera's Heidi Joe Castro you've been
covering this for us here at in Eagle
Pass Texas uh just near the Rio Grande
the people are crossing I've just been
looking at your shot and been seeing
some pretty dramatic pictures just
moments ago what's happening
that's right Cyril these migrants have
been through the waters they have been
waiting some of them overnight and then
for hours underneath this blazing sun
and they are emerging with the help of
U.S border Patrol through this Thicket
of razor wire fencing that was put here
by the state of Texas and they are
delicately step-by-step taking their
first steps on U.S soil this is a very
emotional moment for many we saw some
praying we saw some hugging kissing
their children niggling down to touch
the soil with their fingers for the
first time and it is very difficult for
many just earlier a man collapsed after
emerging from these wires the heat
exhaustion here is a real threat these
are people who haven't had water some of
them overnight until now
and we're just desperately begging for
this assistant to be allowed to cross
through this razor wire these are mostly
adults you are seeing emerging now many
telling me that they're from Venezuela
having transversed many many miles
kilometers of dangerous terrain to
arrive at this point but also there are
some who have children many of the
children were picked up actually by
boats by U.S border agents not having to
climb up the banks and the razor wire
and now another child is actually coming
we're here you know these migrants also
helping each other prioritizing the
well-being of those who seem the sickest
or those who have children and it's
difficult you're seeing people getting
their backpacks clothing caught in this
razor wire who that is indeed very sharp
and Cyril this this is the sort of like
the the climax of their months-long
Journey leading them to this point so
despite the dire conditions that many
find themselves in most once they see us
they wave they smile they say that this
is the moment they feel like that
they've made it
yeah Heidi if you get a chance to talk
to anybody like you tried to do
yesterday if you get a chance to to ask
them a question where they're from how
they're doing please go right ahead and
we'll just follow your lead on this
these are the same people you were
showing us last hour and they were on
the other side of the barbed wire and
they weren't able to move because
there's no way for them to come up do
what they're doing now to come up on the
embankment so this is this is what's a
little confusing when you know you look
at it from the other side of the world
is that it looks like U.S authorities
are on the one hand trying to deter them
from coming in
and then at some point when there are
too many people in this situation just
kids gets too dramatic too dire
especially with cameras watching they'll
go ahead and cut up the barbed wire and
and help them in
yes that's exactly what is happening
it's the
it's the give once the pressure here is
so high that is when this humanitarian
response is elicited and I will try to
ask some of these people
how do you feel
he's from Venezuela
foreign
[Music]
well I just asked him a loaded question
I said why did you come and he said many
reasons about every reason to risk that
for for this to risk this you know for
the opportunity to emerge from a dire
economy for the political persecution
that they feel they're enduring in
Venezuela a lot of these people are also
emerging in worse conditions people you
know just really having gone through
this heat and you know just hobbing
hobbling trying to pour water on their
children as as quickly as they can reach
it it's a very tough situation yeah and
if I'm not mistaken the last words in
his answer when you asked him why he was
coming was you for New Horizons and look
this question that you asked him is the
same question the U.S is going to be
asking him I assume within within
moments right he needs to have a reason
to be there and the reason the legal
reason that that would allow him to stay
would be he manages to get Asylum how
would that work walk us through the next
moments for those people
yeah most of these people are going to
walk a few more meters to what is a
shaded area where they're going to be
processed by U.S border Patrol they
submit their names their identities and
they will be asked you know they will be
asked what their intention is and they
have to say that they want to claim
asylum in the United States and then the
next step is to screen whether there is
a likely chance that they'll even
qualify to submit for Asylum and it's a
very difficult hurdle to to overcome
legally speaking you have to not only
face persecution in your home country
but you have to be from a specific
specific protected group race religion
nationality social status and they have
to have the documents to prove that now
speaking with many of these individuals
who are from Venezuela there is a
special case in the sense that the bite
Administration just last last week
extended temporary protections to
Venezuelans to many Venezuelans who are
already in this country actually they
had to have arrived months ago that is
due to the political situation in
Venezuela so there's also sort of a
gamble here the people who are arriving
newly they're hearing what many are
calling disinformation saying that
they're being allowed to stay in the
United States when really that is the
the end of a long political process that
may or may not turn out the way that
they want but it is true that
Venezuelans who were in in this country
already for several months they can
equal they can apply for temporary
protections meaning they can stay at
least for the time being and all these
other Venezuelans following their
footsteps are hoping to have the same
end result
Heidi it's absolutely remarkable what
you're showing us live these are people
who have come some of them from South
America others from Central America and
they've obviously faced the great many
dangers heat and exhaustion just one of
them some of them Smugglers obviously is
another and now they are where they've
been trying to go all along in the U.S
and now they're going to have to face
the U.S Asylum system and try to
navigate that and as you've explained to
us in the past few hours many of them
will be turned back that's Heidi Joe
Castro reporting from the U.S Mexico
border thank you